Imagine The Terror of being stuck in
this
thousands on a Halloween night out
caught up in a deadly Crush
the party atmosphere quickly turned to
panic as the crowds suddenly surged
[Applause]
[Music]
horrific images show Emergency Services
trying to pull people free partygoers
piled on top of each other
those who were there describe how the
situation spiraled very suddenly like
this wave of people
has come rushing towards us with this
incredible force and like urgency and in
the moment you know I stopped filming
because like it just got really serious
and scary
theater one nightlife District descended
into chaos over 1700 emergency service
workers were deployed trolley after
trolley of the injured rushed away
the dead lay covered in the streets
many of these images are simply too
distressing to show you
it's unclear why the crowd suddenly
diverted down this narrow alley piles of
abandoned belongings paint a picture of
the panic Witnesses said the area felt
much more crowded than usual pandemic
controls only recently lifted here
there were more people who wanted to
satisfy their desire for Joy which they
had restrained over the last two years
crowding the etawan district
I personally think this was a man-made
disaster caused by the loss of control
at the place where there are a greater
number of people than usual
and that's no doubt something the
authorities will explore
Korea's president Yoon suck yo visited
the site this morning the safety of
venues he said should be reviewed
as a president who is responsible for
the lives and safety of the people I
feel heavy-hearted and it is difficult
to control my Sadness the government
will set it as a period of national
mourning from today until the
post-accident management becomes settled
and will put top priority on the
post-accident management and follow-up
measures
officials say the death toll will likely
rise
relatives now racing to local hospitals
and gyms to identify the missing
it's already being called one of South
Korea's worst disasters
a horrifying end to what should have
been a celebration Helena Smith Sky News
in Beijing